[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti
il tema di questa giornata è il
desiderio in cui si il cui significato
originario abbiamo sentito essere
mancanza di stelle io devo ammettere che
le mie stelle le stava già cercando di
costruire a 5 anni la mia casa di
campagna dove sono cresciuto dove crea
il mio teatro delle stelle vi sembrerà
strano ma lo chiamai proprio così quando
in estate questa stanza buia si svuotava
si svuotava dalla paglia
invitavo i miei amichetti che venivano
in villeggiatura nella mia contrada e
coreografa vo meteo sud e veri e propri
spettacoli
ognuno contribuiva come poteva pensate
che avevamo anche il microfono del
cantato di un amico per presentare ogni
pezzo
disegnavamo le locandine invitavamo i
vicini
eravamo dei bambini con dei grandi sogni
ma perché oggi sono qui a parlarvi della
danza e di man
sapete nella famiglia nessuno e
danzatore io non conoscevo la danza però
capito che la danza arriva a tutti
sapete che la danza ha preceduto la
parola
fine dalla preistoria si danzava per
implorare l'arrivo del del sole della
pioggia o per festeggiare il raccolto
tutto ciò che ci circonda e danza
pensate per esempio alle onde del mare
al movimento delle foglie o gli stormi
di uccelli
sapete come iniziato a danzare
con il vento il vento mi faceva da
partner mi muoveva mi spingeva
ancora non sapendo che il vento si
potesse trasformare in sogno e poi il
lavoro
ma ora fermiamoci un attimo e pensate
per voi cos'è la danza
si danza per stare con gli altri per
divertimento per hobby
oppure anche
per attirare l'attenzione di qualcuno
non sapendo che si possono fare anche
delle figuracce
io danzo per evadere da tutto per
scappare dai problemi di ritrovare me
stesso
ma cosa realmente la danza oggi
la danza prima di tutto disciplina chi
sei lezioni di danza impara il rispetto
impara a stare con gli altri
impara a gestire le proprie emozioni
quando ho iniziato la scuola
ho notato che li accompagneranno tutti
così diversi da me
loro non danzavano col vento e nello
sport non c'era la musica
ogni giorno mi chiedevo se ero io
diverso da loro o loro diversi da me
mi accompagni dicevano che la danza non
è da maschi
così decisi di tenerlo nascosto fino
allo spettacolo di terza media volevo
mostrare a tutti che non giocare a
calcio non significava non avere
passioni volevo mostrare a tutti che
la mia passione per la danza era tanto
forte quanto la loro per il calcio
volevo mostrare a tutti che la danza non
era e non è solo una cosa da femminucce
quando ho iniziato
quando a 14 anni
[Musica]
mi sono
inserito intrufolato in un progetto
in una scuola di conversano
intrufolato perché in realtà io seguivo
liceo artistico di monopoly il
coreografo dalla fondazione piccini di
bari giuseppe mintrone notò subito nella
passione per la danza
così mi offrì di studiare gratis anche
perché non potevo permettermelo
ogni giorno a bari per provare a
trasformare quella che era la mia
passione nella professione era durissima
volevano cd volava di tutto in quella
sala però grazie a lui a 17 anni ho
vinto la borsa di studio per il balletto
di toscana firenze
per il corso di danza classica
professionale
di danza classica
contemporanea e coreografia
a firenze potevo finalmente fare ciò che
mi piaceva circondato da che aveva le
mie stesse passioni
però come sappiamo la danza comporta
tanti sacrifici e tante rinunce
i canoni professionali fisici o anche le
pressioni psicologiche non erano per
niente facili da reggere pensate per
esempio al principe azzurro
ecco pensate abbia qualcosa a che vedere
con me
vedevo tanti miei compagni
abbandonare ma io non potevo lasciare la
danza mi faceva stare bene
era la mia amica potevo fidarmi di lei
così fila è finito il diplomato mio
abito al balletto di toscana ho
cominciato a fare audizioni e prassi e
passavo principalmente quelle in cui era
richiesta
l'improvvisazione con in primis azione
come stesso a 360 gradi io e il mio
vento
come danzatore ho lavorato in campi
completamente diversi dagli spettacoli
di danza contemporanea agli spettacoli
di prosa all'opera lirica ai corpi di
ballo televisivi o le comparse nei film
osservavo tanto e coreografi facevo
tantissime domande
e proprio osservando i coreografi ho
capito che
la coreografia
rappresentava il modo per raggiungere
più persone possibili attraverso la
fotografia potevo
parlare delle mie emozioni
sapete se penso a quando ha come ho
cominciato penso che le cose non
potevano andare diversamente
una delle tradizioni della nostra puglia
è la danza della taranta
la cui leggenda ci insegna
che il veleno del pizzico della taranta
si poteva a sconfiggere si poteva curare
soltanto danzando e per certi versi
anche io mi sentivo pizzicato dalla
taranta però il mio veleno era
rappresentato dai miei amici che non mi
accettavano o dai canoni della danza
classica
spostato mia londra ho capito il vero
potere della danza
spostarsi un paese nuovo in cui non si
parla la stessa lingua non è per niente
facile
io poi non avevo mai studiato inglese
prima perché l'ho convinto ed è vero
anche che la danza non ha bisogno di
parole
quindi potuto far danza ovunque così mi
iscrissi a un corso di danza per
professionisti
e la prima lezione
insegnante chiesi a tutti
di urlare di gridare di usare la parola
oltre che il movimento
potete immaginare mio imbarazzo non
capivo assolutamente nulla di ciò che mi
dicevano gli altri però mi lanciai in
questa esperienza
gli altri danzatori mi parlavano in
inglese rispondevano italiano ma la cosa
bella è che ci capivamo la danza aveva
il potere di combattere le barriere
linguistiche
dopo qualche settimana
inizia a lavorare come danzatore in una
piccola compagnia
e le direttrici
notarono subito la mia passione per la
creazione così mi proposero di provare a
coreografare
ovviamente non potevo dire di no
era la mia prima occasione il mio primo
spettacolo si chiamava last lo slide e
trattava il traffico di esseri umani
la fortuna volle che il direttore di un
teatro
assisti a coloro spettacolo
e mi propose v
gli propose di
di provare a partecipare insieme a un
bando per giovani coreografi questi
fondi sarebbero andati a tredici giovani
coreografi in tutto regno unito
insomma per farla breve il primo
novembre del 2011 vinsi bbc per formare
found era l'inizio di un sogno
non era soltanto un sogno avevo la
certezza che potevo fare il coreografo
il mio primo spettacolo davvero
coreografo si chiamava rights e il
trattava il i diritti umani un tema
difficilissimo da realizzare è ancora
più difficile era
spiegare ai miei danzatori provenienti
da tutto il mondo
i concetti coreografici il significato
di quello che volevo esprimere questo mi
spinse ad accelerare con le lezioni di
inglese finalmente
[Risate]
la vita a londra costava anche molto
quindi decisi ad aggiungere alle prove e
alle lezioni di inglese anche lavoro in
un ristorante
e anche lì il caso volle che è uno dei
clienti abituali di questo ristorante è
il compositore francesco germini che
sapendo dalla mia prima nuova produzione
si offrì di comporre le musiche
originarie per il mio spettacolo
anche ristorante si era trasformato in
un posto di lavoro premio spettacolo
ogni giorno trova portata e l'altra lui
impastava cd e li passavo i foglietti
con i cambi per le musiche
col tempo mi sono reso conto che la vita
ci offre tante opportunità
l'importante è saperlo e riconoscerle
accoglierle
per esempio
dopo qualche anno mi sono dovuto
spostare a washington per motivi di
famiglia
e non è per niente felice di lasciare
londra londra rappresentava il mio
inizio da coreografo
ma anche lì dopo poche settimane
scoprì che è il teatro più grande di
washington il kennedy center
offriva ogni giorno spettacoli gratis
per il pubblico alle 6 in punto e
proporsi il mio spettacolo che avevo
fatto a londra sui diritti umani anche
perché rispecchiava le idee del
presidente kennedy e mi diedero subito
una data per lo spettacolo a questo
punto mi servivano i danzatori e una
sala prove così andrà direttamente alla
scuola compagnia più grande di
washington e mostrare il video dello
spettacolo che avevo fatto a londra
l'acqua è subito e mi supportarono
insomma lo spettacolo la prima del mio
spettacolo
statunitense ed è talmente tanto
successo che il washington valle mi
offrì di lavorare come insegnante e
coreografo per la loro scuola ovviamente
non potevo dire di no
ormai sono quasi dieci anni che lavora
negli stati uniti e tante sono state le
occasioni per mostrare il mio lavoro
tratto temi sociali come i diritti umani
la violenza sulle donne
i cambiamenti climatici il bullismo
razzismo l'immigrazione e il pubblico
sembra apprezzare il mix della danza con
temi sociali
perché attraverso i temi sociali
attraverso la danza
possono vedere la realtà con occhi
completamente diversi
ma sogno anche di portare la danza al di
fuori
di posti dei teatri in posti dove non è
richiesto soltanto un biglietto
volevo portare il mio vento anche in
posti
che muovono il mondo
così a un certo punto
ho portato il mio vento anche al
carnegie hall di new york per il concert
for a sustainable planet per la
settantaduesima assemblea generale delle
nazioni unite oppure per la casa da
commissione europea a vienna o giusto la
settimana scorsa per a rappresentare
l'italia ha per la prima volta al
capitol pride di washington
sogno anche però di portare la vita
reale nella danza
la danza ha il potere di cambiare il
mondo sogno danzatori che non
che aggiungano alla tecnica anche le
loro emozioni
sogno danzatori che non pare non
soltanto di fiabe mondi fantastici ma
che parlino
di oggi della vita reale
sapete molto spesso guardando il
balletto classico
in cui ci sono dentro
mi rendo conto di quanto è distante
dalle nostre esigenze
penso che sia veramente importante è
mantenere i classici come il lago dei
cigni lo schiaccianoci ma penso che sia
ancora più importante è portare la vita
reale nella danza la danza il potere di
prevenire o evitare i problemi del mondo
sono pienamente sono pienamente convinto
di questo
però
ho voluto
abbinare anche alla fotografia anche
l'insegnamento perché l'insegnamento
non permette di lavorare con le nuove
generazioni attraverso le nuove
generazioni posso capire i problemi del
futuro le loro esigenze
o bis soltanto lavorando con le nuove
generazioni potrò continuare a crescere
come insegnante e come coreografo
molto spesso mi sono sentito dire
moto c'è flash o ballerine
oggi ha 38 anni mi sento di dire a testa
alta
sì faccio il danzatore il coreografo e
l'insegnante e nessuno onorato perché la
danza rappresenta alla mia voce nel
mondo
il mio desiderio oggi è di continuare a
ispirare le prossime generazioni
è il mondo
dopotutto
il cielo è pieno di stelle quindi questo
significa che c'è spazio per tanti altri
tiratori delle stelle
io voglio contribuire alla loro
costruzione e continuare il percorso con
cominciato in quella stanza buia in
campagna quando ho cinque anni grazie a
tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]